when's the last time Georgia look at you
and I just feel so bad what's the lesson
we got some look at you every [ __ ]
well previously yes but it was a
customer yeah Tiger belly fat do you
ever I feel like yes I already know that
was a good one mistake no no the more
you jizz in your own eye is that one no
no no I hooked up with a tiger really
fan and then the whole Jessica story
came out and that stopped so uh I
already know who yeah oh yeah yes oh I I
already know so you know what she or was
she not at the recording I know so what
you're trying to basically say to me
right now okay this is serious business
yes sir what you and I have right now is
serious [ __ ] business well you're
seeing to me right now is to that
cock-blocked you know from Jessica
blocked all at once I did I did a double
[ __ ] block yeah why would she stop
talking to you don't tell me about the
double [ __ ] block well how do they do it
what do you mean what tell me exactly
what the situation is because I'm kind
of lost
how did Bobby [ __ ] block if you say he
[ __ ] block D twice double yeah I want to
know how that transpired uh the first
one was Jessica that's so cool
that's not [ __ ] blocking save her cuz
that's the one that's the one [ __ ] block
so okay aside from that so I admit that
I like Jessica on the pie and you know
Paul I bet yeah I've ever saw
I look like a complete loser and then
the Torelli banner at that time of girl
who listen to the podcast or the other
place and do well this guy is not the
man he pretended to be now yeah you [ __ ]
block yourself heard this on easy did a
double complex
let me put this out let me just clear
there for you girl who dumped George
because of the Jessica's story him and
Jessica never even so much as kissed
never even so no will you stop texting I
thought I was you cut block yourself bro
what you stop texting her because you
thought that Jessica was gonna van Hecke
woo yeah are you you [ __ ] you know
what dude see what white people do
well you just revealed that you just
stop see what white people do I'm
learning by the spin they spin and they
do their little web of the [ __ ] white
to see and they try to [ __ ] get me
like feeling bad about myself and my
behavior what he did it himself
apologize to me right now doctors gonna
make me apologize look at me right now
spin like apologize for your deceit for
what to see because you accused me of
being a [ __ ] blocker when you [ __ ] block
yourself twice so apologize for that at
least apologize that I got college a
cockatrice you have to George or else
we're never gonna move on sorry what I'm
sorry really how it was Bobby [ __ ] [ __ ]
you twice - you [ __ ] yourself wow
this guy is it
[Music]